so now that we have a prototype we're
moving to the validation stage right
that's right
the validation stage answers the hardest
question in product design
the hardest question in product design
is how do you know if your work is any
good okay that's an important question
it's very important
how we answer this question has
three different stages
at google we use something that we call
triple validation
just like in the beginning we looked at
the problem from the perspective of
business technology and users at the end
we want to validate the solution from
the same three touch points
the most important opinion and the most
important votes and validation is that
of the users so the critical piece not
to miss is the opportunity to test your
prototype with real users
we recommend sprinters and the sprint
lead recruit users from the very
beginning of the sprint so they know
that at the end the users are coming
right
and they have to prepare for it and else
the the all the efforts that they have
spent with prototyping could cause waste
because they don't actually know if this
is solving the needs that users have so
meeting the users at the beginning is
useful to learn their needs and meeting
them at the end is crucial in order to
test
this type of test is called a usability
test or cognitive walkthrough it allows
the team to put the product
or the early prototype in the hands of a
user and watch them walk through all the
different all the different stages
what do they like where do they get
stuck do they understand what the idea
is about and is it solving the needs
that they have and that they expressed
earlier on
it is do i need to explain to the user
what what he needs to do you know what
we like to do in this stage is kind of
like it's based on one of the ideas of
writing show don't tell
a great
design prototype should be able to stand
on its own without too much explaining
generally we'd like to set up the user
and say imagine you're shopping for a
new product or imagine you're looking to
write the review and now tell me what
you see and now tell me what you're
doing from here
so we ask the users questions and ask
them to imagine themselves solving a
specific scenario and we watch what they
do we ask them questions to clarify but
we're not trying to sell the product to
them
one of the mistakes that people make in
this stage is that they imagine this is
a marketing pitch and they start
explaining how awesome the product is or
why they love the idea this is
um
a useful approach if you're trying to
recruit that specific person to buy your
product and they might just because
they're trying to be nice
but this support does not answer the
critical question is the product any
good that you force someone in person to
buy something is very different from
creating something that's popular and
that works on it that people love that's
right exactly
and
are users the only people i want to get
in front of this prototype
well the user validation is one of three
points in the rapid evaluation process
the other two points involve the
business and the technology it's really
useful to test with the stakeholders of
the team is that still still meeting the
business goals is this still answering
um the promises that you made to
investors or the goals that you have as
a company and if yes fantastic and if no
we need to go back to the drawing board
more often than not teams are aligned
with the business goals and the
stakeholders are happy with the results
but if you skip that validation they
might not approve the design or block it
at a later stage so having a quick
check-in with the stakeholders even if
they didn't end the entire sprint can be
very useful at this stage
very cool
another piece that's important here is
doing a technical check a design
solution that's beautiful but no one can
implement it's only so valuable so what
what we want to do is encourage teams to
check in with the technical stuff is
this still going the right direction in
terms of feasibility and if this seems
challenging let's clarify what are the
pieces here that seems like they're
going to take the longest and how might
we be able to point the design in a way
that's not creating hurdles and it's
something that we can test and deliver
quickly
okay so what i'm hearing is we need to
do three validations validate with users
whether it is with business stakeholders
and validate with technology people yeah
these validations can be rather quick or
user tests can be 20 to 30 minutes and
you can test with three or four or five
different people
for most teams the given test with one
person is already a success
the business validation can be a five to
ten minute discussion or longer if the
issue is very problematic um or the
technical validation can be similarly
short five to ten minutes we're doing
this as a best practice um sort of like
covering a checklist to make sure that
all the possible ways in which something
can fail to deliver after the sprint are
addressed and that also people bought
into the solution which makes it easier
to deliver afterwards so what could go
wrong in this stage
that's a great question
what could go wrong is the teams can
be overly confident in their own
solution and skip the user testing that
is a common
pattern that we see with teams that are
new to sprinting they think well we can
do the user testing later
it is true that the user test can be
done separately from the sprint but that
is a mess while the team is together and
they're fresh in the in the in the space
of the all the prototyping it is really
valuable to right away get feedback
if you do the user test with your whole
team present and right after the um the
creation session this keeps the need to
write any research documents and it
keeps all the ideas fresh in their minds
that makes it that much more likely that
the products and the problems will get
addressed in the next phase and what
happens if they don't like the solution
if the users hate it
well if the user's head solution it's a
great opportunity to learn we try to be
humble with our designs
after all we only spend two to five days
working on them we hope that the life of
the company will be much longer than
that so those two to five days were
valuable if we learned something so if
the users don't like something it's a
great time to seek to understand again
so we go back to the first way of
thinking which was let's understand
what is it that they don't like
is there something that could be solved
better
asking questions and probably probing
deeper into the things that then that
users don't like it's a great
opportunity the best time to learn is
that users don't like something it's
right after you have created the
prototype in two to five days and not
after you have spent two years of your
life telling everyone you love and
maxing out your credit card
this is a great idea
so in this stage we take the users we
look we let them play with the prototype
and we listen to them that's right